welcome back to the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gonna get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend that's right [__]
it's [__] Friday it's mother
Trucking Friday bro hey bro how you
doing I'm good how are you doing you're
sitting in front of a gorgeous
impressionist painting in this
artification yes I'm podcasting from The
Hamptons me and Ben taking our first
official road trip with a new vehicle we
drove the new vehicle last night to The
Hamptons and it was a gorgeous ride Ben
hadn't driven it yet if you saw the Vlog
you know that like I had to drive it
home from the lot by myself which was so
scary
um so we're just like loving life with
the freedom of having your own car
amazing I'm so glad you put it to Great
use what are you guys getting up to in
the Hamptons today
well today it's like a little cloudy and
it's still a work day so I'm podcasting
Ben thank God we're staying at this
place I'll tell everyone about it when I
leave it's really cute um we have like
this little cottage with the backyard
Ben is working outside because if I had
to hear his [__] call voice I
seriously like I would blow my own
brains out I can't with my husband's
voice on a call first of all he talks so
loud for no [__] videos so loud are
you ever in the car on a call like I
feel as though my eardrums we're gonna
give up am I ever in a car on a call yes
I swear to God certain times like when
Ben's talking on the phone in the car
something about the pitch of his voice
goes straight to the center of my brain
and I seriously I don't know it's like a
reflex I literally could reach over and
punch him straight in the job like I
don't know what it is it's infuriating
infuriating uh so I hear you have a
backyard I know Theo's not there but
could he have been there honestly I
don't know if this is like a um
a pets pet friendly property I'm sure
that it is I didn't even ask I didn't
realize like what we'd have would have
like enough space there's like a
literally a fenced in yard I totally
could have brought him but Theo's so
happy to be with his grandparents this
weekend it's not even an issue no I'm
sure it's not I just
I think of him I worry about him you
fear for him
no I fear for you and your fears
yeah yeah I mean I fear for everything
I think the toast to this week has
taught us all that it has it really has
that's been a learning lesson it's been
a great week of the toast it has so much
Jacks so much Jacks even though it was
only a four day week we had stassi we
had book launch oh my God not Stasi
being this week I know speaking of book
launch though Claudia and I recorded a
patreon episode yesterday that will be
up right when you're listening to this
episode
um and it's all about the book the
camper and the counts are taking all of
your questions about how I got it
published how I found the illustrator
what the process was like you know the
journey where I pulled inspiration from
right who is the counselor and more
importantly who is the camper and who is
the camper going to be
hmm
thought-provoking the rest is still
Unwritten
the rest is still Unwritten so check
that out patreon.com it's podcast and
video just like the regular episodes of
the toaster if you're missing seeing our
faces today we're there on the patreon
yes today is Audio Only
um and that's because your girl looks
fugly I look so ugly
but I feel at peace you know something
about the Hamptons is very relaxing and
because you're in the Hamptons yeah yeah
but I would have done like Zoom you know
I just hate Zoom episodes
that is well first of all don't call it
Zoom because no we don't use zoom and
any Zoom podcasting is a horrible
experience it's not
it's not a quality experience but we do
have like a pretty good situation for
when we want to do video remote
but you know you're not missing anything
with these faces with these mugs with
these mugs that's what I look like today
like muggio we're a cup we got a couple
of mugs on
mugs you only need to hear our sparkling
personalities and our beautiful voices
yeah I don't know if I would call my
voice beautiful my voice isn't something
like I'm proud of my singing voice yes
but my podcasting voice like I actually
find it so cringe but you wouldn't have
your singing voice without your talking
voice
so true you said it there sister so you
really shouldn't put yourself down
when you sit down to like remote podcast
what are like the things you have around
you that you just need while you podcast
obviously besides your equipment but I
always have I have before
but today Zach was not available to make
me one so just water for me I always
have like a drink I always have Aquaphor
there's like a few things I always just
like need you know maybe I'll put on
some Aquaphor
got a fresh tub but what's better than a
fresh tub about before oh yeah what are
you gonna do since you're not sitting at
your vanity like combing your eyebrows
the whole time I know I'm like in a
different spot I'm like so bored yeah
yeah no maybe maybe podcast maybe like
listen
maybe listen I'll see maybe listen and
learn
listen
to the sound from deep within we've got
a ratio today we obviously have some you
know conclusive updates from The Saga
that's taken over everyone's week the
submersible stuck you know at the
Titanic
it's bad news it could be worse I think
out of all the theories that were
popping around
a lot of people were hoping for this one
so we'll get into that along with some
other just details that's that are
coming out so many about the
circumstances people who are supposed to
be on James Cameron speaking out yes
James Cameron yeah he's not holding back
I mean he's qualified he is qualified
he's been down there I wasn't sure if he
had been but he has spent time down
there he's obviously I think he's been
down there 50 times
is there a safe way to go down
I don't think anything is like
completely safe because it's like an
unregulated whatever but I think like he
went to the best of the best of the best
of the best and he said himself he was
like I've gone down a bunch of times
Always by myself I would never make
anyone come down with me I would never
ask anyone to come down with me because
it's you know it's unknown who like he's
in a one-man vehicle
or like with the professionals who do
this you know he didn't take like a A
co-director or a family member got it
like Hamish
right
okay well we could get into everything
else so so soon but I guess we're kind
of all caught up for the week like what
did I do like oh I watched Kardashians
last night which we have a Kardashian
story so um I'll talk about my thoughts
then okay I didn't watch it yet I've
been seeing like a bunch of stuff but
something kind of like Monumental did
happen to me last night I totally forgot
to tell you what
before we drove out to The Hamptons we
went out to dinner
um and I found a hair in my dish
no
yeah no
I won't silly the name of the restaurant
because it was a clean facility and they
were so apologetic and they come to my
ice cream which was great
um
but I just wanted to let everyone know I
found a hair in my dish you know that's
upset my night was ruined so so should
yours no that's messed up that you would
tell us that
oh some people are eating
yeah okay well I so was I
so was I
damn turdy
yeah so now that I've ruined everyone's
day and appetite I think we can get into
it now we could get into the fast five
stories that you need to know
thanks Jax and today's episode is
brought to you by impossible Foods Jax
let's talk about Hot Grill summer wait
what do you say what Hot Hot Grill
summer grills they need to be hot to be
cooked meat on and this summer
impossible Foods once you and your grill
to join them in making meat history
making meat history got it making meat
history yeah you better get it I love
history I and I know you love impossible
foods and I love meat history
so as you may or may not know impossible
beef is delicious it tastes just like
beef and historically speaking beef is
absolutely delicious that's correct
but impossible beef is made from Plants
also correct
well impossible has zero animal hormones
and 19 grams of protein per serving and
it's better for the planet turdy Lou
correct Jackie O where would you be
without me and where would the planet be
without me and without meat made from
Plants I don't even want to think about
where the planet would be without you
Jackson seriously let's not think about
either of those options but if you're
looking for options on what to grill
grab impossible well done turdy well you
know it's summertime and the living nope
summertime in the grilling season you
missed my joke well done no I heard it I
just I just Breeze past it you didn't
see do you see what I did there I saw
exactly what you did
so anyway start making meat history
today head over to the meat aisle at
your local store grab some impossible
beef or patties and get grilling it's
grilling season you don't want to miss
out do so with impossible foods thank
you today's episode is also brought to
you by Lululemon Lululemon shorts were
made to stretch flex and support the
infinite ways of working out giving you
the courage to LEAP into something
totally new and unexpected so Lululemon
is obviously the go-to destination for
all things outdoors athleisure but it's
summertime we all need our shorts and
they have some of the best shorts we
love the hottie hot short it's their
short with a comfortable range of motion
and flattering fit they allow you to Max
your stride so you can move freely with
confidence they're lightweight Swift
fabric lets in airflow so you can move
without baggage it's designed to Wick
away sweat before you even notice that
it's there carry your Essentials with
two perfectly placed discreet pockets
they also have the Wonder train short
which is their short with a supportive
stretch it also keeps you dry because
it's powered by the everlux fabric the
Wonder train collection manages heat and
sweat so you're staying comfortable and
focused the material is sweat wicking
and quick drying it absorbs moisture and
Wicks sweat away during the most intense
trainings and it's super supportive it
offers extra support so you can do what
you want without interruption
they also have great men's shorts if
you're looking to get a nice pair of
shorts for the man in your life or if
you're a man listening a versatile short
that is up to any challenge the peace
breaker short their Ultra lightweight
fabric means you can train move and
stretch how you want without baggage
each pair of pace breaker shorts is
designed to Wick away moisture so all
that's left is your intention Secure
Storage means you can keep things close
without feeling them bounce around
Lululemon shorts are steamy tested
steeny approved get into Lululemon
shorts at lululemon.com that's l-u-l-u
lemon.com lululemon.com they're also
undercarriage tested and undercarriage
approved you said it there says or okay
our first story is an update the update
on the Titanic submersible debris from
the Ocean Gate Expeditions Titan
submersible was found on Thursday which
would confirm that all those aboard had
perished the Coast Guard said yesterday
the array of debris on the ocean floor
found 1600 feet from the bow of the
Titanic meant that the craft would have
suffered a catfish traffic implosion
sometime after it had been lost one hour
and 45 minutes into its dive to the
wreck twelve thousand five hundred feet
below the surface on Sunday
so I guess there's like no way of
knowing how long
after things went wrong and before it
imploded knowing that it imploded I
think I read it's like a nanosecond it
takes for like your spine like like they
went peacefully
um but who knows what the hours leading
up to that were did it happen you know
the second they lost communication an
hour and a half in that would be you
know best case scenario or were they
sitting there you know freaking out
wondering what's going on so I think
they had no idea what was about to
happen also I'm not sure if you saw but
um a top secret U.S Navy sonar detected
the Titan sub implosion hours after the
submersible loss contact with the
mothership so basically since the 1950s
there have been like there's been audio
technology in the ocean that like the US
has
um to detective enemy submarines are
coming
and those detection systems heard an
implosion that was likely the Titanic
sub uh do they know what time they're
not giving us a specific time but then
the question is why are we just learning
that yesterday
why did we all count down this oxygen
tank oh yeah um and no that wasn't even
legit What well no like yeah it's a
little it's a little shady
um
conspiracy yeah a little conspiracy
because then right after they reach
their conclusion of you know we found
debris and it probably imploded now
we're hearing that the U.S Navy knew
that the day it happened on Sunday
well maybe like the Navy heard it but
like again the ocean is so vast and so
crazy like how are they to assume at
first no at first but like then there's
this huge yeah Mission Station and so
and then they spent millions of dollars
on a rescue mission and so it's like why
did they allow uh all of the different
entities to spend all this time money
and and Hope
if they knew that something imploded in
the ocean at the same time that that
thing went missing I wonder if the
families knew
I don't think so
damn
this whole story is just like Willy
Central like it gives me the willies
yeah oh for sure but I do think like you
said out of all the best possible
outcomes where they don't come back
alive this is kind of best case because
they might have just been you know on
their way down excited and boom before
they could even process like not even a
second less than like yeah they wouldn't
have even known what was happening and
then it was over
yeah I think out of all the terrible
ways this could have went down this was
one of the better ones obviously the
best one would have been them coming
back but um now we're just like getting
so many details about like the people
inside I think a lot of people like are
really drawn and just having a lot of
Sympathy for the 19 year old boy who was
on there
um and I believe it was his aunt who
like spoke to some publication saying he
really did not want to go on this thing
like he was freaked out it was a
Father's Day thing for his dad and he
was just like doing it to make his dad
happy but like he really did not want to
be on that vessel yeah I saw that
so sad so so sad and then also I saw
this morning that there was a different
father-son Duo who were supposed to go
or um the CEO was trying to get them to
do it and the son of that father like he
wasn't he him and his friends like
researched it and was like Dad this is
weird yeah and so they didn't go because
the sun didn't want to go but like the
the dad shared the text messages that he
had like stocked in Rush the CEO and at
one like he said that his son my son's
friend researched what could go wrong
and put a little scare in him I'm trying
to talk him down he's excited to go but
concerned about the danger and the CEO
goes I'm happy to have a video call with
him curious what the uninformed would
say the danger is and whether it's real
or imagined
oh not the gaslighter yeah
so it was Stockton on the ship yes
right so like now it's like who
um who's to blame look who Bears
responsibility for the loss of you know
innocent lives I just but the company uh
and I mean that would be you know
Stockton had he been alive but there is
another Co I think but the waivers that
they signed were so extreme like
I don't they might be Ironclad because
they literally they say death eight
times in the whole thing
yeah
that's so crazy and a bunch of people
who were supposed to go um
this what world renowned diver his name
is Chris Brown which is just beyond
confusing
um he was supposed to go there were a
few people but seeing how Stockton and
like the text messages were sent were so
shady because this thing cost 250 000
and I think he was like offering a deal
for his son and him like a hundred each
it's like so like ranking it was like
last minute pricing because
Rinky Dink
such a terrible story I guess you know
in terms of an ending
this is one of the better case scenarios
like you know imagining them suffering
they're like freezing freaking out for
days on end it's so horrible so
obviously would have been better had
they returned and
you know Live to Tell the tale but I
guess this out of all the ways it could
have ended this isn't the worst one yeah
I just want to know why we didn't know
on Sunday that they heard an implosion
because all week we're like there's
banging on the sea floor like we knew
every little detail of what was
purportedly heard but not that there was
that there's audio technology in the
ocean that picked this up yeah oh so
that's just like a crazy thing to have
audio in the ocean
well it's so crazy because I'm currently
reading this book that's about World War
II and like they're truly um
the girls in the um
the main characters in the book they
work at this like station that is
responsible for decoding German Morse
code and stuff like to see if they'll
crack what the Germans are up to and
like that was their version of like
spying and now it's like imagine if we
had had these little sonars in the ocean
in World War II oh yeah for sure we
would have drowned them Nazis you know
yeah I'm sure that this that these
sonars are a response to World War II
because they have all those like German
new boats blowing up ships and this
technology is from the 1950s which is
right after right
so
that's that on that in the submersible
story I guess so I'm sure more stuff
will come out and literally everything
every headline is just some facet of
this story I think people are really
captured by it all the people who have
ever gone down to the Titanic are
speaking out family members of Titanic
um
victims are like this is a grave site
why is it a tourist destination it's so
true but I also do think sometimes grave
sites are tourist destinations like not
in a negative way but like the Holocaust
yeah the case you're right they're like
museums yeah
and so yes James Cameron I think he did
an interview or something he's been very
outspoken about the whole um
Saga yeah
he is kind of the authority to lay
people such as us on the Titanic no it's
true
and you know it's not like he's uh under
qualified for that role like yeah he's a
movie director but he did he did the
research he's been down there right it's
not like us you know listening to Leo
because he played it Jack Dawson yeah
yeah exactly James Cameron literally
built uh the Titanic in order to make
the movie like he had to
build the ship you know every detail
every all the day like he knows
everything he's well versed yeah he is
and I read that one book so I feel like
I'm like number two
I would agree and I saw the movie so I
think that makes me like number three
and the movie's pretty close it's
historical fiction but they got it you
know
last night at dinner I was with Ben's
family we were obviously talking about
the submersible like what else is anyone
talking about I found out Ben has never
seen Titanic
hmm
is that crazy
now in thinking about it and knowing Ben
it's not yeah
I mean I've only seen it like maybe like
once or twice you guys should sit down
and watch the whole thing it's amazing I
know
maybe like tonight a rainy day titanic
new dinner plans rainy day what about
day Ben's working all day I'm literally
gonna go gallivant on my own or you're
gonna watch the Titanic
yeah I have to see the TV as Netflix
hmm
well
that's that on that yeah really sad
terrible are you ready for our next
story
Kesha and Dr Luke have settled their
defamation case out of court signaling
an end to the long legal drama Kesha and
producer Dr Luke have settled their
definition dispute out of court both
parties announced Thursday with each
releasing a quote related to the
settlement that indicated they mutually
see this as the end of their Road for
their lengthy legal disputes Dr said Dr
Luke said in his statement like he's not
a doctor is he
that's a good question I think it's like
a stage name it's just like rude
because it's hard to be a doctor a
doctor oh maybe he has like his
Doctorate of music maybe he's like a PhD
he's no he's just known professionally
as Dr Luke but his name is Lucas
Sebastian gotwald okay my theory was
very generous
Beyond Dr Luke said in his statement
that he wishes Kesha well while the
singer said that she wishes nothing but
peace to all parties involved as the
court dramas apparently draw to a close
Kesha said only God knows what happened
that night as I always said I cannot
recount everything that happened I'm
looking forward to closing the door on
this chapter of my life I'm beginning a
new one I wish nothing but peace to all
parties involved
so was Dr Luke suing Kesha for
defamation yes
after she had sued him alleged yeah
right
um that's like such a [__] bold thing
to do like it's widely known allegedly
that you know Dr Luke has allegedly
you know
done stuff so like he got accused and he
like technically I think in a legal
sense got away with it and then to go
after someone for defamation I mean
that's [__] balls
yeah
nuts I'm happy for Kesha that this can
be behind her I'm not sure it was like
the exact outcome but I'm sure after
years and years of just like being in
the legal system and not getting
anywhere really
um
it's nice to just tabula rasa it's just
like enough yeah and she's been like you
know putting forth new music and just
like building her career back up and
nobody needs this hanging over their
head
no yeah no I'm sure like yes it's not
exactly how she would have won it's not
real Justice being served but at some
point like I'm sure she just wants to
move on with her life yeah
and as her Dr Luke I hope you somewhere
praying
right I do I hope you still lose
changing
true I hope you find your peace
falling on your knees
praying that song is so good it is it's
probably Kesha's best song
um yeah
sometimes I pray for you at night like
that bridge especially when she
performed at the Grammys with all those
ladies uh
someday you'll see the light
oh some say in life you're gonna get
what you give oh but some things only
God can forget like I don't know how you
don't get chills when you hear that song
They're gonna throw you overboard
they're gonna throw me overboard
there literally are
yeah what do you think is her best song
um I have to pull up her album and I
used to listen to her music like in like
all the time in college and they were
obviously like the classics that we
danced to sit sack like Timber I know
that's her and Pitbull but like that
song is a
certified Bob
is that the same song as
heart beat to the beat of the germ that
is Ben zoffer's number one song of all
time like when that song comes on Ben's
offers [__] popping on the Dance Floor
no it's true it's that good but like
yeah no it's it's good I'm looking at
her album animal and like all of the
songs are so good like read them to me
your love is my drug Tick Tock ooh take
it off because you love me you love me
that one's good uh take it off kiss and
tell another one yeah you do you know
all of these Steven
um but one that I love which is so
Random is Dancing with tears in my eyes
yes I know you put that on the
quarensteins playlist it's just it was
such a quarantine's Vibe yeah uh warrior
die young I mean
no she's like an underrated hit maker
and hope she can just get back to that
now focus on that exactly that's what
I'm saying I'm sure it's just been like
a really toxic negative few years for
Kesha and I'm looking forward to
ushering in Kesha's next next era
whatever that may be yes are you ready
for our next story
is this number three or number two
number three okay yeah I'm ready Andy
Chloe is slamming the insane rumor that
Meghan Markle faked podcast interviews
so oh
Andy is jumping to Meghan markle's
defense after it was claimed that she
didn't conduct her own interviews on the
newly axed podcast archetypes
he um called the rumor insane he said of
course I spoke with Megan and she
definitely interviewed me that's an
insane rumor he told us weekly her
podcast is conversations with people how
would she not have of course she did
well if you read Andy's book you know
that they they did have the conversation
together for the podcast but there were
other people who were on the podcast
just they weren't like major major
celebrities they might have been like
experts or professors and somebody a few
of them were doing an interview and just
said that they were interviewed by a
producer yeah I'm sure for the big ones
the Big Wigs they got Megan but also now
what Andy had said about
um his experience doing her podcast is
also kind of resurfacing of course so
it's like he's not saying he had a great
time but it was Megan but it was her and
he's actually making a lot of news
because he had Kelly Clarkson on radio
Andy and he and he brought up her
Infamous tweet Kelly's Infamous tweet
when the whole Taylor Swift scooter
Brawn Masters thing went down Kelly
Clarkson was the one who like instantly
tweeted like Taylor you should get back
in the studio and just like re-record
all your own albums your fans will love
it and you'll get to own it it was like
so innocent and then that's actually
what Taylor ended up doing
um and Andy was just like asking her
about that tweet and she said actually
like that like created beef between her
and scooter brunch she doesn't really
like work with suitor Brahm at scuder
run called her manager and he like took
that tweet as like an assault on his
name she was like it literally had
nothing to she responded in to Andy she
was like it had nothing to do with
scooter it was just like an idea that I
had because I know owning her Masters is
really important to her and I knew her
fans would support her it was like not
this you know calculated threat to
Scooter Braun and then she later ran
into scooter run and he brought it up
again like she said it was like
completely Innocent but when is Kylie
ever done anything nevarius when has
Kelly ever been anything other than
innocent literally
literally I'm loving all this Kelly
promo though because she's obviously
gearing up for her big album release and
you know Kelly's Making Waves Kelly's
making news yes she is she did like that
Apple beats one with Zane show she's on
I have a question I have a question no
disrespect
Zane Lowe is an amazing interviewer
does anybody listen to that I feel like
like Taylor went on it every it's like a
major stop if you're releasing music you
absolutely have to do that and I'm sure
it has something to do with like you
know wanting you know good placement on
Apple streaming it's like a good
partnership thing but does anybody sit
down and listen to something I think the
the fans of that artist do like right I
did not listen Kelly but I think it's
really for like it's a great place for
the fans to go I don't know that he has
so many fans who listen to every single
episode it doesn't matter who the guest
is I don't think it's meant to be that
sort of show got it yeah I listened to
Luke Combs right right
you're not really listening for like
Zayn you're listening for your favorite
artist
now
what was who had the Apple show before
that everyone was actually obsessed with
Z also with his exact
do you know what I'm talking about no
wait hold on it's important
like Liz Gillies went on it a thousand
times Ariana went on it oh that's their
friends it was an apple it wasn't the
exact same show that was an apple no yes
it was
I don't know actually I think it was
just his like show Zach sang
no because now he has a new show
a podcast but before that he was like
with uh a big streamer I believe it was
Apple yeah what happened to the Zak sang
show
it was canceled after a nearly decade on
the air but what air
he brought it back and he still gets
like major guests and it's it's good but
it was on like a big streamer I feel
like I only ever saw it on YouTube
it was somewhere
hold on I'm on Wikipedia yeah me too
he has a friendship it was from 2012
from 2012 to 2022.
but it wasn't on Apple I apologize
it was on WYD media I never heard of
that
yeah I think it was just his YouTube
show Westwood won I thought it was like
a
no Westwood one it's a radio network
okay I thought it was Apple I apologize
but that was also like a a big place
like everybody used to go they still go
yeah but thank you waves like they used
to and I feel like celebrities you know
artists like go listen to music and
stuff but
unless you're Taylor Swift like
everybody's always sitting down and
everyone's doing hot ones everyone's
like yeah everyone's giving all of
themselves up everyone's in Haley's
bathroom like there's so many different
places to go yeah actually I will say
there are so many different places to go
but like hot ones is actually like so
different from everything else
everything is the same yes these are
good shows no no yeah yeah but I'm
saying like hot ones is actually in my
opinion like one of the probably best
web shows at least the most creative and
most original
um of our time
like shout out to hot ones yeah I mean
everybody literally sits down and
they're like this is not going to be
like other interview shows and they're
all the [__] same
hot ones is actually not like other
interview shows yeah there's another oh
like even carpool karaoke at one time
was a disrupter was a disrupter hot ones
is a disrupter
well you know what else is a disrupter
the toast the toast you know what else
is a disrupter what primarily pure that
is true
if you want to have your healthiest
summer yet and become the most vibrant
version of yourself start here cleaning
up your skincare products swapping for
natural options is a must if you want to
feel good and glow from the inside out
and primarily pure has harnessed the
power of natural ingredients in their
complete line of non-toxic beauty
products from Skin Body baby hair home
you can't forget they're called
following natural deodorant primarily
pure products are handcrafted with real
raw ingredients to optimize your results
and your overall health the testimonials
that flood their Instagram feed their
inbox and their website are proof that
pure ingredients really do create
positive change in your skin you won't
believe the before and after photos and
the transformation transformation
stories from their Community all across
the world from handcrafting natural skin
care creating educational content
cultivating intentional community and
even offering organic facials at their
holistic spa primarily pure exists to
help Empower you to not only improve
your skin but lead a healthier more
fulfilled life Jax and I fell into
primarily pure during your last
pregnancy because you switched to their
natural deodorant right and then we just
started using all their products yeah I
got a package with so many products from
them like room spray natural deodorant
like serums oils and everything is so
like indulgent and amazing and not what
you necessarily might associate with
like clean products so now if I'm ever
looking for like a clean version of
something I'm like what does primally
pure have up their sleeve if you're on
the fence about making the swap to
non-toxic products especially natural
deodorant and skincare check out their
five star reviews at primallypure.com
from customers just like you once you're
convinced use code toast for 15 off your
primally pure purchase that's
www.primallypure.com toast you'd use
code toast to check out for 15 off your
order today's episode is also brought to
you by our besties over at the perfect
bar the original refrigerated protein
bar that you know we love if you haven't
heard perfect bar just launched a new
line of protein bars called perfect bar
layers perfect bar layers are a new line
of crispy protein bars stacked with
three delicious layers and packed with
whole food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut butter and cashew
butter their layer with dark chocolate
or 100 real fruit and then then they are
sprinkled with toasted gluten-free oats
they're packed with up to 11 grams of
protein they come in two delicious
flavors crispy peanut butter and
chocolate and crispy peanut butter and
Berry which is basically like a healthy
peanut butter and jelly they're made
with only whole food ingredients which
is their classic blend of 20 organic
superfoods and they contain no
artificial preservatives so perfect bar
layers are stored in the fridge so you
could stay that say that these bars are
stacked and packed actually what's so
fabulous is I saw somebody Post in our
Facebook group like what is a toast
recommended product that changed your
life I'll go first and she said perfect
bar like it's literally her favorite
thing that was so fabulous to hear and
if you aren't convinced already they're
also non-GMO project verified they're
gluten-free they're soy free they're
kosher and they're low GI the best part
is that you can also Now find them in
the refrigerated sections at Targets
Nationwide so perfect bar knows that
it'll be Love At First Bite they're
offering you a chance to try their new
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar directly into your venmower PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thank you
Claudia you're welcome now I'm craving a
perfect bar yeah no I'm getting like a
little hungering what are you gonna do
for lunch I don't know it's a good
question you should get some Hamptons
Fair yeah I should I should like hit the
local Main Street I think I'll head to
Main Street in your car
in my vehicle that is mine are you far
from Main Street where you're staying I
don't know but I don't think so I mean
we only got here last night I literally
haven't left this room because I'm about
to podcast and that's true then I'll go
out wow I'm jealous of your options
thanks girlie swirlie okay our first
first of the next two stories
Rihanna appoints a new CEO for Savage X
Fenty the music Superstar and business
Mogul is stepping down from her role as
CEO of her lingerie brand Savage X Fenty
she is being replaced by former
anthropology CEO Hillary super according
to Vogue Rihanna will remain executive
chair in an interview with 40 over 40
super said she wants to be a relatable
leader she said I take my responsibility
as a role model very seriously it is
important to be able to visualize your
future and I hope that I'm helping the
young women on my team do that by seeing
a strong kind relatable leader but but
also by being resilient and fearless
when things don't go as planned okay I
love that but like to call yourself a
role model is like kind of a crazy thing
to do
um moving on what is this giving Jackie
it's if you and I are on the same
wavelength like I will die
okay let me think like this is Rihanna's
company that she started and they
brought in the CEO for e-commerce oh the
intern yes yeah I guess but I feel like
Rihanna doesn't get pushed out of
anything
no by the way in the intern Anne
Hathaway was getting pushed out I think
Rihanna like wanted to get somebody I
think they said like they're really
trying to focus on e-commerce right now
so they need someone with like a major
e-commerce background I don't think this
was like a slight towards me on I think
she probably wanted somebody to come in
she's also like so busy with Fenty
beauty that like she really can't be
everything to everyone I think Fenty
beauty is probably her baby and it's
bigger
um and also just like being a mom she's
about to give birth she wants to be able
to take maternity leave I think she's
trying to enjoy her life she's built
these companies and she's been the face
of them this entire time to get them to
where they are but eventually you need
to be able to offload it a little bit
and so it's not the company needs to
exist without you right so she's taking
like a more
passive role while people run the
day-to-day I think it's really smart
it's what's best for like her ability to
be a part of these companies otherwise
you just burn out yeah no I don't think
this is like suspicious at all like I
think people are always so quick to be
like Rihanna's being pushed out no this
is like not suspicious at all I think
it'll probably be really good for the
company because like Savage Xfinity I
know it's like worth a billion dollars
but like if feels kind of mysterious to
me like where do you even purchase it
online I'm seeing a picture here of a
storefront in what looks to be like a
mall sort of complex
but I agree it just feels it feels very
like I know it exists and I know it's
big but like I've never seen it yeah I
agree it feels kind of like exclusive
and not ubiquitous yeah perhaps that's
what Hillary's here to do
perhaps that's what Hillary is your end
to be a role model well I just want to
say she the first sentence said I take
my responsibility as a role model very
seriously so I feel like maybe the
question was like yes how do you feel
about being a role model
you know what that's so fair of you to
say and I take it back and you're right
she definitely no one would just say
like hey how are you well I'm a role
model you know like yeah no you're right
I feel like role model was in the
question and we could probe and find her
40 over 40 interview which I didn't know
that was a thing
oh I actually that's so funny that you
brought that up because I was just
reading this thread on Twitter of all
the people who've been named Forbes 30
under 30 who are now in jail
oh wow what are they in jail for
Elizabeth Holmes oh or they're either in
jail or like were arrested Martin
shkreli that pharmacist guy oh okay so
they like you know the businesses were
fake yeah um wait there was more uh hold
on wait a minute oh Sam Baker Friedman
the FTX guy of course it was about you
it was actually really funny that is
really funny so then what about people
in their 30s if it's like 30 under 30
and 40 over 40 then like while you're in
your 30s you don't you're just like a
relevant you're unqualified for any list
is it 40 over 40 or under 40 over
oh yeah I guess Forbes doesn't see the
30s as like a valuable generation
good to know it could be 30 in their 30s
love that I think that's cute
yeah I mean I guess what like what
they're like subconsciously saying it's
like if you do something successful
under the age of 30 like that's
impressive and if you do something over
the age of 40 and we're still talking
about you like I guess you're impressive
too not really I mean people over the
most successful people are over the age
over the age of 40. yeah
I don't know I think they just like
lists
I think they love a list yes they're
making a list and checking it twice
checking it twice to take the doors down
yeah
so congrats on the new CEO
yeah congrats congrats congrats Hillary
our fifth and final story some cute news
from Kourtney Kardashian she's showing
her baby bump progress and saying it's
been a minute since I've done this she
did a q a asking for clean body care for
during pregnancy because as she said
it's been a minute since she's done this
she should listen to our ad for primally
Pure
by the way this is like must be so crazy
to like experience pregnancy
in like two totally different places in
your life like yes I feel like most
people like bang out all the kids and
then it's like they're in their baby
making era and then after that they're
and they're like you know after baby
making era but to like experience it
when you're like older and wiser and
she's clearly like in such a happy
secure place and her life is probably so
crazy yeah and I'm really actually
curious like what things she's going to
do differently in her pregnancy that
like I wonder if she'll have like a
natural birth I don't know if like with
her with rain like did she still have an
epidural I'm sure I could watch an old
episode of Kardashians and like find out
like I can see her giving birth at home
in the bathtub oh my God please no
I've never seen that she probably won't
because of her age and I think that just
like automatically makes her happy makes
it high risk yeah no you're right but
I'm loving this journey for her I wasn't
in studio on Tuesday when you guys like
broke the news but I think we talked
about it but I just am so so happy for
her me too also like because last season
like watching her you know get her eggs
and then knowing because you know that
was a year prior knowing that it like
didn't work out for her that's like so
tough and then seeing her um she'd like
posted on on social media a few times
when she was going through IVF and like
all those things like her body was just
like so beat down and she was like so
bloated and she had like bruises
everywhere
um I don't think like that Journey made
her happy at all so I think she gave
that up for the sake of her own
happiness and then to just like
naturally get pregnant is so it's like
it's like the definition of like God's
plan yeah and you can I'm really happy
for her feel how
how happy like
how much they want this and how happy
they are so I'm happy for her too
um but I did watch Kardashians last
night and it was good
there were highs and lows like Lowe's
being the way that they're talking about
the stulting about a fashion show I'm
sure it was like a huge deal
for cam but it was starting to give like
SNL where it's like this is now the
fourth episode about this thing yeah and
it's acting like Kim has literally like
gone to the Moon actually I mean they
wouldn't even be as impressed by that as
they are Yeah by this fashion show and
it's just like
I it's really really cool but like
she put outfits together four episodes
yeah she put out like I mean it's just
like
it skims to me is a bigger
accomplishment than yeah this so yeah
just the way that they're all talking
about it I'm like
I I'm not feeling that from what I'm
seeing I'm feeling like this is a really
cool opportunity but like we're not
Reinventing them let's move on let's
move on so we the other thing that's
happening is like Courtney is still like
processing her feelings she has a long
conversation with her stylist like about
how they picked the looks for the
wedding it felt a little like
planned you know just yeah just so she
could get out there how like Dolce and I
thought this was interesting like Dolce
and Gabbana wanted the girls to be in
like their lemon patterns you know
there's that like the whole Motif that
they have going on now is very
like painted lemons and flowers and
everything and the girls and I I'm sure
it was led by Courtney stylist who was
like the head stylist of the weekend was
like no we want to wear like these 90s
looks we won like Dolce 90s oh by the
way that even though it sounds like a
planned conversation that is pertinent
information yes no I agree
so that it needed to be planned so even
though Kim went out of her way not to do
like the Madonna collection and the lace
collection it's so Niche it's all the
same it she was it was all 90s stuff
like and it's like
why couldn't they do something else but
clearly everyone like loves 90s and Kim
has been like into 90s style for a while
but so has Courtney so it just turned
out to be really similar and then like
Kim was saying you know Court needs
Madonna dress that she wore like I
actually wore that in 2018 and I didn't
choose it like okay but then I I've seen
Clips even though she said that they
didn't choose any looks from Courtney's
wedding like Courtney actually cited
like a butterfly dress that she wore and
it was on the runway in black and
Courtney Warden red and like I don't
think it's a big deal but it's like
there was a crossover you know there was
cross-pollination and like with these
two girls where everything is like so
heightened sensitive like they each are
going like Tit for Tat and they're each
making Fair points about how like the
other has wronged them
yeah the thing is and then the clips
that I've seen it's like they're both
but more so specifically like Kim just
being like mean about it you know like
it's still your sister like that clip of
like Courtney saying uh Kim saying that
Courtney has no friends but like all of
her friends are telling her how similar
it was like that's just mean yeah so at
the end of the episode Kim has a
conversation with Chloe like about how
she's like feeling about Courtney and
she is lit up like she's not feeling
synthetic like she's mad that Courtney
is like taking away from her moment and
like making about her and everything and
like even Chloe was like you need to
when you do talk to Courtney you cannot
have this energy like how dare you think
I need your permission like you have to
just like listen to what she's saying so
next week is the conversation
right so has the show even happened yet
oh yeah yeah that was the show was this
week okay okay
there was so much there was this show
and the dinner and all the accolades and
everyone just like kissing oh my God we
did it like the biggest deal and like
I I just it's so crazy like what like as
an outsider what we see is like Kim's
accomplishments and what she sees as her
accomplishments because I honestly about
SNL like you're doing them a favor by
doing SNL like
and she's giving them so much credit
credit yeah so like I don't see this and
I guess you know everyone's journey is
their own and I feel like probably for
Kim like after so many years of being
like like a joke in the fashion world
like she takes the acceptance from the
Fashion World so seriously it's like the
most important thing to her when like
she doesn't realize like what we see
like you are the fashion world like you
don't need them
like we all look to you but what's
important to her like that's her own
journey I just like I don't see that I
feel the same way about like the Met
Gala like even last season they had a
few episodes about like Kim's Marilyn
transformation and the Met Gala and like
just the way she speaks about the mecca
was such reverence and like it's a it is
it is a huge deal for her but like for
us we're just like it's a party right
and honestly if you and your family
weren't there like less people would be
watching right they really wouldn't care
right so maybe she just can't see
herself the way that we see her and
that's a shame and I think also she
never wants to appear ungrateful or like
that these moments don't mean something
to her
um yeah but no we get it like it's
meaningful
yeah
so uh we'll see you next week but this
is really like going on a long time now
this is dng storyline though it is meaty
so I'm not complaining entirely
yeah honestly just though ever since you
really changed my mind last week like
I'm so seeing Courtney so I just like in
Little Things
um and there I guess like a clip I saw
it go viral on Tick Tock she's in back
in La having dinner with like Travis two
of her kids a bunch of Travis's kids
um and the in her confessional the
producer is like well your family's not
there and she's like this is my family
and I think a lot of people took that as
a slight to her own family but no I
think that's like what you're supposed
to say when you're like a blended family
I thought it was actually really sweet
she's like this is my family right and
like her kids were there right and
that's not her saying that like her
sisters and her mom are not her family
but these people are her family too yeah
I agree like it didn't and also I'm
pretty sure at least the way they showed
it it was at the same time that they're
all in Milan so like why would they be
at Travis's restaurant opening
oh is that what it was yeah it was for
his um Crossroads vegan Eatery in
Calabasas
cute like they support each other's
ventures in the Kardashians and they're
doing that in the barkers too yeah right
like Travis did like a Lemmy collab
Courtney did a barker Wellness collab
like it's it's Synergy oh yeah I don't
think there's a shortage of the two of
them collaborating yeah but I think it
works for them but in the same way that
like Kim went to Tristan's basketball
games
um and technically like supported him oh
oh you know I see yeah where the girls
weren't there because girls weren't
there for Travis but like one they put
it in the episode as the girls were in
Milan so why the [__] would they be at
Travis's restaurant yeah say the timing
wasn't so and the girls just didn't go
to Travis's restaurant opening
that's interesting and that's rude
yeah because they keep I mean they're so
supportive of Scott like they keep
everyone French Montana like Chloe's
ex-boyfriend they keep everyone in the
fold so like Travis who's actively
married to Courtney and it's such a good
step dad to those kids like you should
support
yeah so I think that's what the producer
meant and also like
if they were I could also see Courtney
not having invited them because you know
it's like Travis's thing and she doesn't
want them to like Eclipse yeah they
don't then it becomes like a major red
carpet event it's like Kim and Chris and
Chloe like if everyone's there but it
travels don't you want that for for an
opening of a restaurant like
I don't know Travis opened it with his
Chef like
it was okay it was kind of low-key the
mayor was gonna have to watch the
episode there was a ribbon cutting and
guess who cut the ribbon
Penelope rain
stop that's so [__] cute I hate no
I'm telling you like
there's like a Courtney Renaissance
happening yeah and like I love I love
all the girls but I am seeing her side
that just to see her side but I just
want to say like that doesn't mean in
the past I think she's like had points
that I've missed necessarily no like no
like when like I feel like this dng
thing I'm it's reminding me of maybe if
you had a business that you were
passionate about and I thought Kim was a
hundred percent right for that like I
said I'm Not Looking Back Now and seeing
no no but I think Courtney was like for
a few years like in a place in her life
where she was really just genuinely like
not so happy and she was taking that out
on everyone and now she's in a place
where she's so happy and so at peace and
it feels like everyone's having a hard
time like being happy for her well that
but also it's like everything in the
past you could just chalk it up like oh
Courtney's like not happy and she hates
everything and she's just like a hater
but now it's like no we know Courtney is
like deeply happily she's not just
sitting around festering trying to like
make fights and hate everyone so if like
something is bothering her like it's
worth just hearing her out and I thought
she made a lot of sense but I mean still
my takeaways like Kim should have done
in the show and in the conversation
preview for next week it looks like
Courtney says you chose like the money
and the deal over my feelings and like
that's just like a little
cringe like yes yes I chose like this
huge business opportunity over your
feelings yes
and we need to put your feelings aside
and Kim should have but like it would
have been nice if her to like include
Courtney in it in some way or do
something yeah
yeah
um
they don't know like that's what it is
like at the end of the day these two are
not closed and like all those rumors
like a year ago saying that those two
like weren't talking like I fully
believe them now oh for sure they
literally weren't talking and even I
think Kim like called Courtney to tell
her that this was happening
just to like tell her but it was never
like you know and you should walk down
in your wedding dress that would be so
cute if she just included her like and
that would have eased Courtney
completely and then Courtney would have
been involved
but no
no
um okay well I have to watch that
episode even though you just spoiled the
whole thing for me thanks no there's
still like some cute stuff there Chloe
was being really funny
isn't she always yeah yeah you'll enjoy
it
all right well I enjoyed this I enjoyed
this great week of the toast thank you
so much for being here and for listening
you guys
um we're back Monday so thank you so
much for listening to the Joseph Monday
Morning Show we deliver the fast five
stories
and YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up also available
did we are hope you guys have an amazing
day and we'll see you Day weekend
weekend and head over to anywhere you
get books to pre-order my children's
book the camper and the counselor which
is now available everywhere for
pre-order and will be released in
October and if you're missing us already
there's a new episode on the patreon of
Charity and I
me and Jerry me and charity love ya
bye